[Music]
straight ahead online crime daily
he's incredibly happy grateful he wants
this time right now
to spend with his family
they're incredibly relieved
that this nightmare is finally over
after days of deliberations the jury
comes to a decision in the ohio murder
trial of william houston but first
complete johnny depp and amber heard
coverage i was sort of not allowed to be
right not allowed to have a voice johnny
depp is back on the stand plus you start
to slowly realize that you are in a
relationship
with your mother
in a sense how depp says his childhood
affected his relationship with amber hur
and i believe that was
about the lowest point
in my life we are live in fairfax
virginia for a recap of deb's testimony
so far law and crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmeyer johnny
depp is back on the stand for day two of
his testimony in the multi-million
dollar defamation suit against ex-wife
amber hurt
law and crime network's jesse weber is
live at the fairfax county courthouse
and jesse you are inside the courtroom
for dep's testimony right
that's right brian yeah today was all
about depp reinforcing the notion that
like his father who was abused by his
mother he was constantly abused by the
woman he loved amber heard he kept
taking that abuse but would never return
in physically fighting her he would
always try and find ways to escape
whether going to another room or
actually booking another hotel room now
he alleged that heard slapped him threw
things at him and even punched him and
in fact we and the jury all heard this
incredible audio tapes where amber heard
in fact acknowledges that she attacked
johnny depp and complained about the
fact that he does actually walk away now
he also said that she was very verbally
abusive to him as well and would turn
insecurities or facts that she would
share with her against him for instance
saying that he was a terrible father
something that really hit him home based
on his upbringing but in one of the most
dramatic and frankly disturbing accounts
depp said that heard was responsible for
severing his finger when she threw a
bottle at him
i
was leaning
like this in the chair
looking at her first bottle went
and got the other bottle shot
takes the second bottle which is the
larger one
i'm in this position again
and my my
hand is on the edge of the
the bar like like that you know leaning
over the fingers
like that and uh
she threw the large bottle
and it
made contact
and shattered
everywhere
and
i honestly didn't i didn't feel the pain
at first at all i felt no pain
whatsoever
what i've felt was
i felt heat
i felt heat and i felt
as if something were dripping down my
hand you know
and then i
looked down and
realized that the
the
tip of my finger
had been
severed
and
i was
looking directly at
my bones
and it gets a bit stranger because depp
says then he went into a panic state and
actually took the blood to right on the
walls you really can't make this stuff
up ryan
not at all jesse depp gave an example of
herd faking an injury what was that
about and how is that going to affect
her when she eventually testifies yeah
that was a notable moment he had talked
about how he actually get engaged in a
physical struggle with amber heard and
kind of put her in a bear hug
and as a result he said he briefly
touched her and she claims that he
actually broke her nose and head butted
her he says i didn't do any such thing
and he said that she took a napkin and
there was what he at first she claimed
was blood on it she threw it out when
she left the room he looked at the
kleenex and it was nail polish so the
idea that she would allegedly fake that
attack helps his narrative that she also
faked injuries later on to ultimately
get that restraining order from the
court so that was a really pivotal piece
of testimony from him yeah it really
goes to her credibility now i know one
point that the jury in the court
actually heard audio recordings were
hurt amidst the throwing things at depth
when he tries to walk away is this the
smoking gun in the case for depp
i mean i think it is it's really
important because if she's acknowledging
she attacks johnny depp and she's saying
that he walks away that kind of not only
fuels his narrative but makes him seem
more credible and it's going to be very
interesting when she takes the stand to
explain that away and i should note that
when those audio recordings were
finished up there were murmurs
throughout the entire gallery everybody
was talking about it yeah i mean that
can't be helpful for her case now jesse
direct examination ended wednesday
afternoon with depp flat out saying he
never physically or sexually assaulted
her and that he lost all but everything
what do you think the cross will focus
on
so
that's a good point and there's a lot
they could pick upon but i'm not sure
they're going to focus on some more of
the
extemporaneous matters about his family
or anything that i think they're going
to really focus back on what we're here
for the washington post 2018 article
really focus on that focus on what was
exactly alleged in that article and how
did it really affect your career you
know johnny depp focused so much on
these false allegations from uh amber
heard but from 2016. he really didn't
focus maybe enough on the article itself
and how it damaged him so if i were them
and trying to defend against a
defamation claim from that article i put
all the focus on that article yeah i
definitely think that's going to be the
cross-examination but don't forget
there's a redirect where he might be
able to get back on the stand with his
uh attorneys and maybe they'll solve
some of those issues but thank you as
always jesse i know we're going to get
back to you in a few minutes as well
still ahead on law and crime daily our
johnny depp live coverage continues
we heard about the finger injury but
what contentious topic led to the
explosive fight in australia that's
still ahead on law and crime daily
[Music]
welcome back more now on the johnny depp
and amber heard trial out of virginia on
wednesday jurors heard what happened
when dev injured his finger he says it
was a result of a fight about a post-op
agreement with her
she kept saying
i'm not even in your will
i'm not even in your will
[Music]
i thought that was an odd thing to say
um
especially since i i don't think anybody
had had time to change wills or
anything of that nature
um
so those things just didn't
it felt uh
wrong and and she could not let go of
the fact that uh
i was in on this
post-snap agreement
and that i was trying to trick her
into uh
essentially getting nothing if uh
if something were to happen she was
irate and she was
possessed
and when i tried to remove myself as i
normally would from a situation
and that is to say you know as she's
hammering me
with with uh
sort of brutality brutal
words being called and
kiss her to lawyers or
or uh
or uh
um
that didn't fight for her or stand up
for her
joining us today is l.a county public
defender philip dube co-host terry
austin and jesse weber live from the
depp heard trial jesse
do you as the ucs depp was testifying or
do you think sorry his death was
testifying that he was on the offensive
or defense in this suit
that's a really good point remember he
is the plaintiff he has filed a
defamation lawsuit but let's not forget
he's also defending himself against a
100 million dollar counter claim from
amber heard today felt more like
defending himself against the counter
claim because the more that he can show
that amber heard physically assaulted
him the more his claim the more her
claim that she says that he made up
these allegations against her basically
she accuses him of operating a public
smear campaign calling her a liar and
fabricating all these details it makes
her case weaker and so i think that's
really where the focus was today
obviously he was trying to defend
himself and say that the claims she made
about him being a wife beater were
completely false but it felt like to me
and maybe the jury that it was more
about defeating her counter claim yeah
now terry do arguments about not being
in the will or prenups and post nups
paint hurt in a negative light
especially since her counter claim is
double that of of depths
absolutely no question depp's testimony
today painted her in a negative like
look she did not want to sign the prenup
she did not want to sign the post nup
she complained about not being in the
will it seems like the entire
relationship was for money she was very
calculating and she as you mentioned
filed a counter claim for twice the
amount of money she definitely filed for
divorce right after he said he was going
to file for divorce another sign that
she is calculating she recorded
conversations secretly i think the
entire deposition
uh the entire testimony everything that
we heard from depp today sounded like he
is a cold calculating individual yeah
i'm not trying to speak badly on prenups
post-nups do as you do but just from
this it seems a little odd phillip heard
gave maybe her first reaction to depp's
testimony because she's been pretty
stoic the entire time we saw she cringed
a bit about the post-nup argument how'd
that come across to you
oh are you kidding i'm sure she was
shocked that they even raised that
because now
that is a motive for her to fly off the
handle and show some of her violent acts
of aggression up to that point in the
marriage you know despite it being
dysfunctional and toxic you know all of
a sudden now you have a physical act of
aggression where money is the root of
that evil
so not only is she not getting a nickel
and not only is any of that property
being converted to community property or
to equitable distribution he is leading
her and he wants out she wants to have
the last word and i think she was
waylaid by uh the evidence of that
prenup yeah i mean stoic during the
arguments part but a little bit of
emotion when it's argument plus money
i'm wondering if the jury caught that
jesse as always thank you as always for
your stellar reporting from the scene
and we'll continue with more in this
case when you come back coming up on law
and crime daily our capital gavel
coverage continues in the johnny depp
and amber heard defamation lawsuit still
ahead we take a closer look at dep's
direct examination how he says an
abusive relationship with his mother
affected his marriage to her
[Music]
welcome back we continue our coverage of
johnny depp versus amber hur as he exits
face off in a multi-million dollar
defamation suit we're taking a closer
look now at dep's testimony as he
compares his relationship with amber
heard to his relationship with his
mother
ahead of deb's testimony jurors heard
multiple witnesses describing an abusive
relationship between depp and his mother
depp's sister testified when their
mother was physically and verbally
abusive towards death he would run off
and retreat on tuesday depp himself
compared that alleged abuse to his
relationship with heard
my
personal experiences which i
gave to miss heard
those those things were
those those those facts were used
against me
um
as as weapons
it was not to help the relationship it
did not help the relationship it wasn't
meant to help the relationship it was
meant to feed her
[Music]
need
for
conflict
which has a need for conflict which is a
need for violence
it erupts
out of nowhere and
what i learned the only thing i learned
to do with it is exactly what i did as a
child
retreat
just take a step back which i told her
we need to remove ourselves
from each other even for an hour a day
anything
this
this
can't go on
no one can live like this you know but
why did i stay i stayed
i suppose because my father stayed
i suppose because i had been in that
relationship with vanessa
and that was lost
and
i didn't
i didn't want to
i didn't want to fail
need for conflict need for violence
terry
depp is connecting the dots between the
abuse he suffered uh from heard and what
he saw with his parents and what he
suffered from his mother
what do you think the jury is connecting
when they hear this type of testimony
you know they spent a great deal of time
on direct testimony about depp's
childhood maybe a little too much but i
think it was important depp was
explaining his relationship with his
abusive mother for instance his mother
called him one eye because he has one
bad eye amber called him an idiot and a
bad father and his mother was physically
hitting him amber threw objects at him
she admitted on that audio you heard
that she was throwing pots and pans and
clearly she hit him she punched him so
you know we heard how
the father was stoic and he did not you
know respond to the mother's abuse deb
was trying to say he was doing the same
thing he was just being you know passive
and running away from it just like his
father so important testimony yeah i
think like a lot of young boys or even
when they grow up i'm just trying to be
like my dad i'm trying to try to do my
best philip what are the photographic
evidence that we're seeing in this trial
really showing us and telling us about
who was the actual victim in this case
well the one photo where the finger was
severed is very telling because uh
unless you believe the text message that
johnny depp sent to his doctor saying
that it was self-inflicted accidentally
then you have to believe that he was
covering for amber during one of their
little arguments where she flew off the
handle and threw that sharp object at
him that clearly was a sort of a mini
act of mayhem and by the way that
carries several years in prison in
california for that it's a very very
violent felony
that was clearly not a defensive wound
if you will but it looks like it was a
direct act of aggression yeah i mean
same thing in new york what's that
disfigurement i think it's a b felony
you can do quite a number of years in
new york so i think covering up makes
sense if you don't want your wife to go
to jail well thank you both on the
coverage of johnny depp and amber heard
when we come back ohio versus william
husso after weeks of testimony and days
of deliberation a shocking verdict is
handed down still ahead the fate of
former doctor william russo
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily ohio
former icu dr william hussell is a free
man after a jury acquitted him of all
murder charges wednesday this after
weeks of testimony and about 33 hours of
deliberations the former icu physician
was facing 14 counts of murder
prosecutors said from 2015 to 2018 whoso
had ordered excessive amounts of
fentanyl and other drugs to patients at
mount carmel hospital in columbus ohio
the jury was clearly convinced by the
defense team's argument that the doctor
was simply giving end-of-life comfort
care and wasn't intentionally killing
his patients throughout the week's long
trial jurors heard from hussell's
co-workers expert witnesses and several
family members of the alleged victims in
the case the jury entered into
deliberations last week to determine if
whoso would be convicted of murder a
lesser charge of attempt to murder or be
acquitted and initially they were
deadlocked on wednesday morning judge
michael hallbrook read the jury's
decision on each of the 14 counts
relative to count one we the jury in
this case being duly impaneled and sworn
find the defendant not guilty as to
count one of the indictment for murder
and not guilty to any lesser offense
signed this
signed by each and every juror this is
the 20th day of april
2022
count 14. we the jury in this case being
duly impaneled sworn by the defendant
not guilty as to count 14 of the
indictment for murder and not guilty of
any lesser offenses signed by each and
every jury this the 20th day of april
2022.
juror foreman is this the verdict of the
jury
yes it is your honor
shortly after court ended whosoever's
defense attorney held a virtual press
conference on the jury's decision
he's incredibly happy grateful he wants
this time right now
to spend with his family
they're incredibly relieved
that this nightmare is finally over
this verdict speaks to not only william
but all of those doctors and nurses out
there
who are
attempting their best to give comfort
care in a very
difficult situation
and and they don't need to be looking
over their shoulders wondering if
they're ever going to get charged with a
crime this was a scary trial for for me
and for all of us involved because we
knew what was at stake and that was the
future of comfort care the reality is um
william hussell was an innocent man
always has been and always will be
pillow from deadlocked to not guilty on
all 14 counts why do you think the jury
came to this decision
my hunch is there was just one or two
loan holdouts
and i think that they were trying to
conflate reasonable doubt with comfort
care and malice of forethought that
there just simply was not enough
evidence in the final analysis to show
either an express or an implied intent
to kill recognize that every hospital
has an icu a ccu a mortality rate and a
morgue in the basement and to suggest
that everybody's going to come out of a
hospital alive is just simply
you know fanciful
so in the end i think the jury and
perhaps the one or two loan holdouts
realize there truly was reasonable doubt
as to his state of mind yeah i mean it
did take them 33 hours to get there so
there must have been something they were
thinking about terry do you think this
trial could change the medical
profession in ohio maybe implementing
standards for comfort care and creating
a law for assisted suicide
well you know i do think ohio could
certainly make their standards a little
bit clearer so that this doesn't happen
again but i do think that the verdict at
the end of the day was the correct
result it took them a while to get there
but they very carefully looked at all of
that evidence and i think it was more
than just that the prosecution didn't
prove you know beyond a reasonable doubt
i think they looked at the evidence i
think that they saw that the patients
were near death that there were consent
from the families in each and every case
that the colleagues of dr hussell
thought he was brilliant and
compassionate and i think at the end of
the day that won the case
all right quite a long case but fully
acquitted on all charges thank you both
and thank you for joining us here on law
and crime daily we'll see you next time
on discuss justice in america
[Music]
you